[موسيقى]
مساء الخير اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من
الرياض
عن بدء القمه العربيه واجماع على اذاعه
التدخلات التركيه الايرانيه في المنطقه
اللوجستيه المتكامله في الرياض تقدموا 650
مليون عميل من ثلاث قارات
مجلس الوزراء السعوديه يوافق على انشاء
المجلس الاعلى للفضاء برئاسه الامير محمد
بن سلمان
تقدم السعوديه عشره مراكز في مؤشر
المستقبل خلال العام الحالي
قضار العماني تعيش موسم الصرب تقليد سنوي
ومهرجانات ترفيهيه لسكان وزوار السلطه
نبدا التفاصيل من الجزائر حيث يستمر توافد
الزعماء وممثلين الدول المشاركه في القمه
العربيه اخر الواصلين كان رئيس المصري عبد
الفتاح السيسي وقبله الامين العام لمنظمه
الامم المتحده انطونيو غوترج بصفته ضيف
شرف في القمه العربيه ما يتوافق قاده
الدول العربيه على الجزائر للمشاركه في
اعمال القمه العربيه الحاديه والثلاثين
المزمع عقدها اليوم حيث وصلت صباح اليوم
رئيس جمهوريه الصومال رئيس اذربيجان الهام
علياء بصفته رئيسا لحركه عدم الان
وعشيه القمه كده الامين العام المساعد
للجامعه العربيه حسام زكي للعربيه ان قمه
الجزائر ستعيد التاكيد على رفض تدخلات
تركيا وايران وشدد زكي على ادانه التدخلات
الايرانيه كافه في المنطقه كما اعرب عن
امله في ان تتجاوب المغرب والجزائر مع
جهود الحوار لا نريد
القمه في حدثتها تكون
يعني مسار للخلافيه بالعكس هي المفروض
ونامل كنا جميعا انها تكون
يعني هي دافع للالتقاء والحوار
همم كون انه حصل بعض الامور
واستطعنا احتوائها في حينه بالفعل همم لكن
بالنهايه همم هذه قرارات دول وقرارات قاده
وهمم جلاله الملك اتخذ قراره بنعرف
اييي وثيقه بكل التطورات التي حدثت همم
يعني انا عاده لا افقد الامل
والدبلوماسيه هكذا لا يجب ان تفقد الامل
ذكرت وكاله الروسيه ان الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتن وجه رساله للقاده العرب
المجتمعين في قمه الجزائر ابدا بوتن خلال
الرساله استعداد موسكو لتعزيز العلاقات مع
الجماعه العربيه
والسياسيه بمنطقه شرق الاوسط بما فيها
القضيه الفلسطينيه يجيب حلها على اساس
القوانين الدوليه المعطرف بها عالميا مع
الاحترام الكامل لزياده الدول ووحده
اراضيهم وشددت الرساله على ان الوضع
الدولي والتحديات الراهنه زيدان من الحاجه
الى جهود جماعيه منسقه ويعزز اهميه منظمات
مثل جامعه الدول العربيه
من القاهره مستشار مركز الاهرام للدراسات
السياسيه والاستراتيجيه الدكتور حسن ابو
طالب دكتور حسن حياك الله معي يا ولد في
نشره الرابع قمه تعاقد تحت عنوان لم الشمل
لكن في ظل الخلافات المغربيه الجزائريه
التي القت بظلالها على هذه القمه كما يرى
الكثير ربما ايضا غياب عدد من زعماء وقاده
العرب المهمين والمؤثرين
هل
القمه يمكن القول بانها
فشيله قبل ان تبدا
يعني من الصعب
القول بان القمه فشلت انا في تصوري وفي
تقيمي ان مجرد انعقاد القمه في حد ذاته
ايا كان العدد القادم من القاده العرب وهو
الوضع المؤكد الان انه في حدود الثلاثي
القاده العرب هذا في حد ذاته يعني عمل طيب
وخطوه ايجابيه للغايه نحن قد افتقدنا
القمم العربيه في خلال العوام الثلاثه
الماضيه لاسباب المختلفه وطبعا طب فقمت
فيها بعض الخلافات وتفاقمت فيها بعض ما
يمكن ان نسميه بالتباينات في المواقف بين
بدء عدد من الدول العربيه القيمه هي
مناسبه كما هو معروف لالتقاء القاده العرب
وايضا التبحث يعني بقدم عالم من الاباحيه
وبقدر نعالي ايضا من
الحرص على تجاوز اهل الخلافات هذا في حد
ذاته بالتاكيد بعض القاده العرب الذين
يعني غابوا لاسباب مختلفه لديه ممثلون همم
مشاركون في القمه وبالتالي فالدول نفسها
لم وان كان ايضا الحدود على مستوى القمه
على مستوى القيادات العليا هذا امر يضيف
للقمه ويعطيها زخما كبيرا وبالتالي انا
اتصور ان القمه في حد ذاتها رغم الخلافات
التي حدثت في المرحله الماضيه عمل ايجابي
وندعو اليه البناء عليه فيما المرحله
المقبله هل يمكن المراهنه عليها في ظل
يعني الملفات المطروح همم ملفات السياسيه
الاقتصاديه
وغيرها يعني من بناء على مخرجاتها
المتوقعه
بالتاكيد
الدكتور حسن تفضل يعني بالتاكيد نعم نعم
المتوقعه يعني بتراعي الظروف العامه التي
حدث فيها هذه القمه وانا في حد ذاته اذا
كان هناك بعض الامور التي يتم التوصل
اليها ويتم الالتزام بها على سبيل المثال
استراتيجيه عربيه للامن الغذائي هذا في حد
ذاته امر ايجابي للغايه نحن نعلم ان هذه
القضيه هي قضيه محوريه الان في الامن
القومي العربي ككل لكل البلدان العربيه
سواء التي لديها قدرات اقتصاديه تستطيع ان
تستود من خلالها المزيد من
الاغذيه والمزيد من الحبوب لكن الباقي
باقي الدول ومعظم الدول العربيه في حاجه
الى هذه الاستراتيجي هذا امر ايجابي
للغايه ان يكون هناك توافق على دفع
المصالحه الفلسطينيه الى الامام وانت
تتحول الى فعل الى فعل على ارض الواقع في
ظل الظروف التي تواجهها القضيه الفلسطينيه
والهجمه الشرسه من اليمين الصهيوني
الاسرائيلي هذا في حادث ذاته قرار ايجابي
بالتاكيد بعض المناقصات موجوده فيما يتعلق
بمساله غياب الحوار ما بين المغرب
والجزائر ونحن نعلم ان هناك قرارات يعني
ذات طابع سيادي من كلا البلدين حاله دون
ان يكون هناك حوار يبنى عليه انهاء هذه
الخلافات نحن نامل بان يكون هناك حوار يتم
تحت النظر جامعه الدول العربيه لانهاء هذا
التوتر المغربي الجزائري نحن مع كل خطوه
تؤدي الى لم الشم العربي بصيغه حقيقيه
وليست بصوره يعني جزئيه همم الرئيس الروسي
فلاديمير بوتن وجه رساله للقاده العرب
المجتمعين في قمه الجزائر داخل خلالها
استعداد موسكو لتعزيز العلاقات مع الجامعه
العربيه
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط هذا اليوم العالمي
يتغير همم العرب الى اين يتجهون تحدثت
فيها عن حاله الاستقطاب الحاد اليوم في
نظام العلاقات الدوليه بعد بالروسيه
الاوكرانيه هل نفهم من هذه الرساله ان
هناك توجها بالفعل الى هذه الحاله من
الاستقطاب المقصود من هذه الرساله من قبل
موسكو وجر المنطقه العربيه وجامعه الدول
العربيه ناحيه موسكو ومعسكريها في مقابل
معسكر الغربي الامريكي وهل الدول العربيه
قادره على التعامل بحياديه في هذه الحاله
اليوم
يعني اقول حينما تحدثت عن فكره الاستقطبات
انا تحدثت عن توجه حقيقي يعني بدا قبل حتى
الحرب في اوكرانيا الاستقطبات موجوده في
ال- في قمه النظام الدولي والجميع بيسعى
الى مزيد من التحالفات ومزيد من المؤيدين
لمواقفه ضد الطرف الاخر العالم العربي
نظرا لمكاناته سواء على الصعيد
الاستراتيجي وعلى الصعيد الاقتصادي وعلى
الصعيد الجغرافي وعلى الصعيد الجو السياسي
وايضا على الصعيد ما يمكن ان نسميه
بالادوار التي يمكن ان تقوم بها الدول
العربيه الاساسيه والكبيره في المنطقه
سواء على الصعيد الاقتصادي العالمي او على
الصعيد السياسي والصعيد الامني هي
المستهدفه من كل الاطراف والعالم العربي
يدرك هذا يدرك هذا جيدا وبالتالي انا في
تصوري ان قمه ووافقا لبعض التصريحات التي
استمعت اليها والتي وسطها لي عدد من وزاره
الخارجيه العرب هم يدكون ايضا مثل هذا
الوضع الصعب جدا التي تمر به العالم ويمر
به المنطقه العربيه وبالتالي فنحن لسنا
حاجه الى ان نكون جزءا من الصراعات نحن
بحاجه ان نكون جزء من تسويه هذه السرعات
على قمه النظام الدولي العالم العربي مؤهل
الى ان يكون يلعب دورا توازنيه بين هذه
الصراعات وبين هذه الاستقبابات
الرساله الرئيس بوتين هي رساله في تصوره
هي رساله تقليديه لانه في كثير من
المناسبات العربيه الجماعيه كانت توجه مثل
هذه الرسائل سواء
من قبل الولايات المتحده
بالتاكيد دلالاتها مختلفه هو القضاء العرب
في تصوري وانا في ادراكي انهم مدركون عمق
اللحظه واختلافها عامه سبقهم من لحظات
وبالتالي فالانحياز لهذا الطرف ضد هذا
الطرف ليس في منطقه العالم العربي
والاستقبابات ضد مصلحه العالم العربي
الجمله تفصيله شكرا جزيلا لك من القاهره
من الدراسات السياسيه والاستراتيجيه يا
دكتور حسن ابو طالب
رابع مستمره فيها بعد قليل
لمده اسبوعين مناورات عسكريه بين القوات
الجويه السعوديه والنظيرتها اليونانيه ضمن
تمرين عين الصقر ثلاث
اهلا بكم من جديد في السعوديه تم تدشينه
المنطقه اللوجستيه المتكامله على مساحه
تتجاوز ثلاثه ملايين متر مربع ضمن حدود
مطار الملك خالد الدولي في الرياض ستعمل
المنطقه التي تعد الاولى من نوعها في
السعوديه على خدمه اكثر من 650 مليون عميل
من افريقيا واسيا واوروبا فضلا عن استقطاب
ابرز الشركات العالميه في ظل تحول قطاع
الخدمات اللوجستيه
تفاصيل اكثر عن هذه المنطقه المنطقه
اللوجستيه مع زميله العنود العبدلي
دوده الاعمال
من حول العالم شهدت الرياض بالامس تدشين
المنطقه اللوجستيه المتكامله التي تاتي
امتدادا للمبادرات الوطنيه الخاصه بقطع
اللورسيات وسلاسل الامداد اكثر من ثلاثه
ملايين متر مربع هي المساحه التي ستقام
عليها المنطقه اللوريسيه المتكامله ضمن
حدود مطار الملك خالد الدولي ومن المتوقع
ان تخدم هذه المنطقه اكثر من سته او 600
200 و50 مليون عميل من ثلاث قارات وهي
افريقيا واسيا واوروبا شركه ابل هي اول
مستثمرين الرئيسيين في المنطقه اللوزتين
المتكامله وفق ما كشفه وزير النقل السعودي
في حفل التدشيني بالامس مميزاتهم عديده
وحوافذ ستحظى بها شركات وكذلك لمستثمرين
في هذه المنطقه من ابرزها انظمه الجرد
المتطوره المخصصه للتجاره الالكترونيه
وتوفيرها
هربتين مباشره بين المستاجرين والموردين
والعملاء والجهات الحكوميه اضافه الى
مزايا ضريبيه على انشطه الصيانه والتصنيع
والتجميع ولجذب الاستثمارات مشاهدينا لابد
من بيئه عمل ايجابي وبهذا المبدا فقد تم
السماحه للمستثمرين الاجانب بتاسيس شركات
وتملكها بنسبه 100% في هذه المنطقه فضلا
عن تسهيلات اخرى وقد يتساءل البعض مشاهدين
لماذا كل هذا الحراك في جعل الرياض مدينه
اللوجستيه وزير الاستثمار السعودي كشف عن
مستهدف لرفع مكانه مدينه الرياض لتكونها
ضمن اكبر عشر مدن اقتصاديه في العالم وان
يفوق الناتج المحليه الاجمالي ثلاثه
تريليون ريال سعودي في حلول عام 20 30
هذه المنطقه اييي منطقه لوجسيه منطقه
تصنيع منطقه خلق قيمه مضافه
مرتبطه بالمطار
تستهدف اكبر 100 شركه على مستوى العالم
لاقامه مجمعات لوجستيه مجمعات قيمه مضافه
تصنيع خفيف
مناوله في هذه المنطقه وتم اليوم الاعلان
عن اول شريك
ومستثمر بهذه المنطقه هي شركه ابل اللي
افتتحنا اليوم همم موقعها او مركزها
للتوسيع اللي يخدم ليس فقط سوق المملكه
وانما سوق المنطقه بالكامل
يتواصل اجتماع القمه الاديان في جزيره
تبال الاندونيسيه التي تتولى رابطه العالم
الاسلامي رئاستها بشراكه مع هيئه النهضه
العلماء الاندونيسيات تستمر حتى يوم
الخميس الثالث من نوفمبر وهي القمه
الدينيه الرسميه الاولى في تاريخ مجموعه
العشرين بحضور الامين العام رابطه العالم
الاسلامي رئيس نهضه العلماء الاندلسيه
جميله
سلطان السلمي اهلا سلطان اجواء القمه لهذا
اليوم كيف تصفها
اهلا بك خالد واهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه
العربيه بالفعل يوم واحد يفصلنا عن انطلاق
اعمال قمه الار توني وهي اول قمه الدينيه
لمجموعه العشرين تستضيفها رابطه العالم
الاسلامي بطبيعه الحال بالشراكه مع هيئه
نهضه العلماء الاندونيسيه هنا في جزيره
بالي وبحضور ورعايه الرئيس الاندلسي طبعا
هي بكل التاكيد قمه تاريخيه تعتمد للمره
الاولى هنا في الجدول الاعمال الخاصه
الرسمي لمجموعه
تونس سوف يتراس هذه القمه الشيخ الدكتور
محمد العيسى الامين العام لرابطه العالم
الاسلامي وكذلك باشتراك مع الشيخ يحيى
خليل ثقافه رئيس نهضه العلماء المسلمين
وسوف تستمر حتى الثالث منه نوفمبر طبعا
هيحضر هذه القمه اكثر من 200 شخصيه دينيه
وعالميه من مختلف دول العالم ملفات بطبيعه
الحاله خالد سوف تطرح عبر مبا منتدى بناء
الجسور بين الشرق والغرب من اجل السلام
سوف يتم عقد اكثر من سبع جلسات عامه
باضافه الى جلسه الافتتاحيه طبعا راح
يتناوب عليها القاده الدينيون على القاء
كلمات ومناقشه القضايا التي يواجهها
العالم الاسلامي
اليوم وكذلك الدوره المرتجه الذي يمكن ان
تسهم بها الاديان وقد بالضبط سوف يتم نقاش
لقضايا اللاجئين وكذلك قضايا همم المسلمين
في كافه البلدان الاجنبيه وما يعانون من
اشكاليات او حتى تحديات وصعوبات هذه ابرز
ملفات كذلك ادخال الدين ليكون اداه للحل
والسلام في الحروب العالميه على سبيل
المثال حرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه مؤخرا شكرا
جزيلا لك سلطان سليمان المفضل العربيه
تشارك القوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه في
مناورات عين الصقر ثلاث المقامه في قاعده
سوده الجويه في جمهوريه اليونان خلال
الفتره من السابع وحتى ال20 من نوفمبر
الجديد
القوات الجويه السعوديه في التمرين الى
تعزيز التعاون بين القوات الجويه الملكيه
السعوديه ونظيرتها اليونانيه ورفعي مستوى
الجاهزيه القتاليه للقوات الجويه لتنفيذ
المهام من خلال تنفيذ رحلات عبر الحدود
الدوليه واداء المهام العمليات والتدريبيه
وتبادل الخبرات العسكريه
وافق مجلس الوزراء السعوديه على انشاء
مجلس باسم لمجلس الاعلى للفضاء برئاسه ولي
العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وفي الجلسه
التي عقدت اليوم برئاسه الملك سلمان وفقا
على تعديل اسمه هيئه الاتصالات وتقنيه
المعلومات الالهيئه الاتصالات والفضاء
والتقنيه اضافه الى الموافقه على مذكره
تفاهم بين هيئه الرقابه ومكافحه الفساد في
السعوديه وهيئه النزاهه ومكافحه الفساد في
الاردن في مجال منع الفساد والمكافحه
ومذكره تفاهم بين الهيئه السعوديه للفضاء
ووكاله الفضاء الايطاليه للتعاون في مجال
الانشطه الفضائيه للاغراض السلميه
حقيقه السعوديه تقدما ب 10 مراكز في مؤشر
المستقبل الاخضر خلال العام الجاري مقارنه
بالعام 2021
مجله ام اي تي تكنولوجيا راديو التابعه
لمعهد مساء التقنيه
تقدم السعوديه في المؤشر بعد اطلاقها
مبادره الشرق الاوسط الاخضر والرياضه
الخضراء بالاضافه الى اعلانها عن الوصول
الى الحياه الصفريه في العام 2060 من خلال
تطبيق نهج الاقتصاد الجزائري الكربون
من الرياض كبير مفوضيه السعوديه لاتفاقيات
المناخ المهندس خالد بوليف المهندس خالد
حياك الله معي في نشره الرابعه من
التقدم في السعودي في هذا المؤشر المؤشر
المستقبل الاخضر ما هي دلالاته ولماذا
اصلا السعوديه تتجه للسير نحو المستقبل
[موسيقى]
الامير محمد
همم
اهم
صورها السلام
[موسيقى]
راس المملكه انه هناك ثلاثه
مهمه جدا
كان اولها في 220 عندما
خلال الفتره للخروج في نهدر الدائره
الكربونه هذا النهج الشامل والمتوازن كان
هو اثر قوي جدا
يعني ياخذ الاعتبار جميع ظروف الدول بما
فيها الدول
سنه ذلك همم مبادره السعوديه الخضراء
وسط الاخضر اللي تزوجت هذا النجاح فيه
يعني مجموعه 23
[موسيقى]
ما هي المعايير التي يتم على اساسها تقييم
عمل السعوديه في سياستها البيئيه من قبل
هذا المعهد او هذا المؤشر
مقاومات
رئيسيه اا يتم دراستها في تقييم الدول في
هذا المكان
اولها طبعا
واهميه الدور
الكربون لانه فعلا
اعتمدتها
المخرج الثاني هو تحولات الطاقه
وهنا ياتي اهميه التوازن ما بين المحاوره
الرئيسيه لهذه التحولات اللي هو امن
الطاقه
وتاكد من التنميه
وانجازات الطاقه ان تكون همم يعني همم
صوره همم بالاضافه الى
التعامل مع التحديات
الخاصه
مهم جدا للتحولات وهذا حديث المملكه اا
يعني كبير يعني نتقدم
ال ال ال ال المؤثر
انها تاخذ
بالمجال الاحمر كذلك الابتكار والتقنيات
النظيفه واخيرا السياسه الاخيره اريد جميع
المحاور حديثه المملكه
وانا اتابع يعني مراكز هذه الدول المتقدمه
في هذا المجال ايسلندا وغيرها من الدول لا
حط انه هذه الدول تتركز على جانب واحد همم
في هذه المعايير وبالتالي ينظر لها ويتم
يعني مراقبه تحركات فيه لما السعوديه
تعتمد على اكثر من نموذج او اكثر من معيار
هذا كيف سيؤثر على مساله تحركها بشكل همم
في هذا المؤشر او في غيره في سياسات هل
يبطئ او يسرع هذا التحرر
في الوقت الحالي هو هو حقيقه لانه العديد
من هذه المؤثرات ترحل على انها اللي ذكرته
في اوروبا في هذه الدول ولكن بعد ما يعني
تم اقرار ااا نهدر الكربون اللي هو ياخذ
محاور اخرى
التحكم في المصدر من الملوثات ايضا ازاله
الكربون من الغلاف الجوي لو جمعنا الثلاثه
المحاور هذه همم
الكربون انه همم يعني المملكه باذن الله
تكون من يعني الدول
المتقدره في هذه
المؤثرات ولكن بشكل عام يعني ما ننسى انه
همم يعني المملكه عندها حتى كثيره في كثير
من المؤخره الموجوده
عمل جبار في هذا المكان الطقم الذي قبل
المملكه تعتبر الاولى في الطقم
المملكه المملكه 50% من همم
انتاجها في الكهرباء من الطاقه المتجدده
ويعني ما في احد همم يعني عام 2003
ولا نرى انه في اي دوله اخرى يعني سوف
اتصل الى هذا التحدي يعني انت كمان تقنيه
الجديده
التقنيات التقاط وازاله الكربون وكذلك
موضوع ازاحه الوقود السائل اللي بالفعل
يعني طبق كبير في ان انا متعدده في هذه
المعاشات لا ننسى انه السعوديه الخضراء
فيها 60 مبادره صحيح همم
وضع التكلفه خلال عشره سنوات القادمه في
هذا المجال المملكه قالت انه احنا باذن
الله
اشكرك شكرا جزيلا على هذه الافاده من رياض
كبير مفوضيه السعوديه لاتفاقيات المناخ
المهندس خالد ابو الليف شكرا
في رابعه بعد قليل
طفر العمانيات تعيش موسم الصرب تقليد سنوي
ومهرجانات ترفيهيه لسكان وزوار السلطنه
اهلا بكم من جديد نفذت وزاره التربيه في
الكويت ما يتم تداوله في وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بشان العوده لنظام الدراسه عن
بعد مؤكده ان الامر غير صحيح ومشيره لانها
تعمل على تفعيل منصاتها بشكل دوري بهدف
تطوير قدرات المعلمين على استخدام منصه
تيمز وعمل الصيانه الدوريه لها تحسبا لاي
طارق
خطوط اليوم في العاصمه السعوديه الرياض
فعاليات ملتقى الابداع الاعلان المقام في
مركز الرياض الدولي للمؤتمرات والمعارض
هذا الملتقى الذي ياتي بتنظيم من غرفه
الرياضه التجاريه شهد طيله ايام الثلاثه
مشاركه 46 متحدثا من نخبه القطاع من
الداخل وخارج السعوديه كما شهداء اقامه 16
جلسه حواريه وسبع ورش عمل و 24 معرضا
مصاحبا
ضميلينا في استديوهاتنا نائب رئيس لجنه
الدعايه والاعلان في غرفه الرياض المهندس
سامي الرشيد عند سامي حياك الله معي فينا
ما هي نتائج وكيف كانت فعالياتو الحمد لله
هذا نتيجه ثمرات عمل الزملاء في لجنه
الدعايه والاعلان في غرفه الرياض كانت
الفكره فقط هي تاسيس ملتقى يعنى بصناعه
الدعايه والاعلان في السعوديه ومتخصص فقط
في هذه المجال على مثل المعمول به في دبي
في القاهره في عده مناطق دول صنعه الدعايه
والاعلان فيها تحت صراحه بحضور كبير وعلى
النمو الكبير اللي حصل خلال اربعه هو خمس
سنوات الماضيه همم قررنا ان نطلع بالمؤسسه
هذا تحت مسمى بلكونه وبالتعاون مع الكليه
في مصر
14 او 15 نسخه سابقه في مصر وكان يعني
منتقايات اللي حضرت شارك كبير وسمعه فكان
المتقاعده بشراكه معها وكان الصراحه
الشراكه مثمره جدا استحضرنا جميع التجارب
والتقليد للملتقيات الموجوده في هذا
المناطق ولا في اهداف معينه ما نقدر نقول
تقليد لا هو فقط نبغى الموجوده في مصر
وكانت صراحه يعني تجربه جدا يعني مثره
وكانت خلاقه
وملهم العرس كبير جدا من الحضور وعلى هذا
الاساس قررنا انه قدوما يعني في في هذا
الملتقى وبالعكس يعني دائما يكون ملتقى
سنوي يكون عشبه ما يكون همم بكل صناعه
الدعايه والاعلان والمهتمين بها
والمتخصصين والدارسين والطلاب كذلك كل اجل
التعزيز هذه الصناعه وتصيلها وتوطينها
كذلك كيف شفته حجم المشاركه في النسخه
الاولى
في خلال يومين تقريبا كلها بيعات من دون
يعني بدون اي تسويق ورش العمل الحمد لله
كان الحضور ويقبل عليها جدا كبير كميه
اتصالات ورسائل تواصلوا معنا من جهات
وشركات
وراغبين بالحضور لكن نعدهم باذن الله
تعالى خلال السنوات الجايه للملتقى يكون
على مستوى اكبر واوسع لحتى يلموا ويكون
لكل احد مهتم بالصناعه هذه حضور وموطى قدم
داخل الملتقى همم
في نتائج في اهداف متاخر بالاضافه طبعا
الى انه يكون في منصه تلتقي فيها الشركات
والمتحدثين المناقشه نزلت العلاقات
والابداع ايضا لكن في نتائج اخرى متوسخه
من خلال هذا الموقع
يعني على راسها الدعايه والاعلان هو في
النهايه همم مهاره وموهبه فما هو مجرد فقط
مويه احنا عندنا المواهب خلاقه ومبدعه
لكنها تحتاج فقط الى تطوير والصقل فاحنا
من خلال هذا المنطق نحاول قدر الامكان
احنا نعزز ونستغطب المواهب ونعمل على
تطويرها الاجل تقديم مال دعائيه نستطيع ان
نحنا ننافس فيها في كان وفي عدد من
الملتقيات الكبير العالميه نكسب فيها
جوائز لما نشوف بعض بعض الدول اا الدول
الاوروبيه والدول كذلك شرق اسويه نلاحظ
عندهم حضور كاسح جدا في كان لما نتكلم على
مستوى الدعايه الاعلان الدول العربيه ما
يزال عدد المنافسه فيها جدا ضعيفه او
تنافسنا بالاصح في متر ضعيف بسبب عدم
تاصيل الصناعه هذه وتوطينها وعدم
الاستثمار فيها من قديم نحن الان عازمين
على ان احنا نستمر فيها ونعتبر حقيقه يعني
مشاركتنا في هذا الملتقى تاسيس تاسيسنا له
هو جزء من الاعتماء من هذا القطاع والجزء
كذلك ايضا من واجبنا الوطني والمجتمع
اتجاه اتجاه البلد يعني احنا نعزز هذا
الصناعه اللي لها مردود جدا كبير على
الاقتصاد جدا كبير على حركه اتجاه التجاره
وكيف تستمر فيها هذول يعني مجموعات
الموهوبين اللي قلت انه يعني كانوا
موجودين برامج
اللقاءات معنيه انها تحاول قدر الامكان
انها تصدر هذه المواهب وتطوره اكثر وبنفس
الوقت ايضا يعني نحاول قد ما كان احنا
نلفت الانظار لها احيانا الموهوب يحتاج
فقط الى لفت نظر يحتاج الى ميلفت لاجل ان
يتبنا نحاول اقدر ان احنا نلفت الانظار
لها نفتح الموهوب ابواب التواصل مع
الشركات كبر الشركات المحليه والعالميه
لذلك حرصنا للملتقى ما يكون حكر فقط على
الشركات المحليه حتى الشركات العالميه
نحرز قدر الامكانيه كلها همم تواجد الاجل
ال- يستطيع الموهبه انه يعني همم يجد
البيئه المناسبه اللي من خلالها تتجلى
موهبته ويتمكن من خلالها لانها يعني يحول
موهبه الى اعمال ومشاركات وهمم ونتائج
اعلانيه يستطيعنا يعني يكبر معه ويسمع
فيها ويؤثر على الناس
وتفكروا في النسخه الثانيه
راح نبدا ان شاء الله على الاسبوع القادم
لاجل التخطيط النسخه الثانيه
والعافيه كل واحد فينا متحمس كل احد فينا
متفوق النسخه القادمه
رئيس لجنه الدعايه والاعلان في غرفه
الرياض المهندس سمير شكرا جزيلا شكرا الله
يحفظكم
الى الرياضه ما محمد القرصه
[موسيقى]
شكرا جزيلا خالد اخبار رياضه حياكم الله
يابان الثنائي
من سته وعشرين لاعبا لكاس العالم
بطموح عالي وبشكل اهم من الخبره في
النهائيات ولم يتجاوز منتخب اليابان من
قبل الدوره 16 في كاس العالم لكن مبارياته
يستهدفه دوره ثمانيه رغم الوقوع في
المجموعه الخامسه التي تضم المانيا
واسبانيا واستريكا
اكد انتر ميلان ان المهاجم البلجكير من
اللولوكاكو يعاني من اجهاد في عضلات الفخذ
اليسرى وسيخضع للمراقبه هذا الاسبوع
للتاكد من مدى الاصابه ويعتقد روبرتو
مارتينيز مدرب بلجيكا ان غياب روميلو
لوكاكو الذي لا بديل له عن كاس العالم
سيجبر فريقه على تغيير طريقه اللعب لكن
المهاجمه لم يتاكد غيابه حتى الان واثقا
لما اعلنه طبيب الفريق ويعاني لوكاكو من
اصابه في عضلات الفخذ الخلفيه بعد انعدم
اخرا من اصابه ابعدته شهرين ستبدا بلجيكا
مشوارها امام كندا في الثالث والعشرينها
من الشهر الجاري
يطمحون ليفربول الانجليزي في التقريب من
ضيفه نقل الايطالي حين يلتقي الفريقان في
الجوله الاخيره من دوري المجموعات بدوري
ابطال اوروبا
واضمننا نابولي وليفربول التاهل ثمن
النهائي لبطوله الاوروبيه لكن يتحكم على
ليفربول ان يتجاوز ضيفه اذا اراد انتزاها
صداره المجموعه الاولى من نابولي بفارق
ثلاثه اهداف او اكثر بينما يكفي نقول
التعادل للاحتفاظ بالصداره
اتلتيكو مدريد كان خرج من سباق المنافسه
للتاهل الاقصائيات في مجموعه الثانيه لكنه
ينافس حاليا بين ليفربول على المركز
الثالث
المؤهل للدوري الاوروبي وهو سيواجهه مضيفه
البرتغالي في الجوله الاخيره
وتتضمن هذه المجموعه اثنين من مقاعد
الثمانيه الشاغره في حاله سبورتنج لشبونه
البرتغالي فبيسعه الاكتتاب التعادل بملعبه
الالماني الذي يجب عليه ان يفوز كي يستمر
في دوري الابطال حيث يملك سبع نقاط في
المركز الثاني متقدما بفارق الاهداف على
فرانكفورد الثالث
من ناحيه اخرى تختموا منافسات والمجموعه
الثالثه بلقاء الانترنت
في المباراه الافتتاحيه للمجموعه
ولاول مره منذ اعوام عديده سيمثل اسبانيا
فريق واحد في ثمن نهائي دوري الابطال بعد
خروج برشلونه واشبيليه واتلتيكو مدريد من
السباق لكن ما هو دور الالمان في ذلك
من دوري ابطال اوروبا الا في مباراه واحده
من اصل ثمان مواجهات
مدريد
بهدفين لهدفين امام باير ليفربول في
الجوله ما قبل الاخيره ليفركوزن ساهم في
سقوط رفاق سيميوني بعدما تغلب عليهم ذهابا
بهدفين مقابل لا شيء
حظو برشلونه العصر وضعه مجددا في مواجهه
بايرن ميونخ ضمن مجموعه واحده في دوري
الابطال الفريق الكتلوني عانى امام نظيره
الالماني ليفشل بالخروج من مبارياته ولو
بنقطه حيث خسر ذهابا وايابا ما ساهم في
هبوط برشلونه الى الدوري الاوروبي بعد
حلوله في المركز الثالث خلف البيار وانتر
ميلان الايطالي
[موسيقى]
بروسيا دورتموند كان ايضا احدى الكتائب
التي لعبت دورا في اسقاط الاسباني من
البطوله الاوروبيه بعد ما تسبب الفريق
الاصفر بشكل مباشر في اقصائي اشبيليه اسود
الفريق الاندلسي بالفوز عليهم ذهابا
باربعه اهداف مقابل هدف قبل ان يتعادل
الفريقان ايابا بهدف لكل فريق
ريال مدريد الفريق الوحيد المتاهل من
الانديه الاسبانيه لم ينجو ايضا من كيد
الالمان حيث تعرض لخساره عن طريق لايبزيك
في الجوله ما قبل الاخيره لكنه كان ضامنا
للتاهل من قبل فوز ان عشق امال لايف زيك
في التاهل الى الدوري المقبل من المحفل
الاوروبي الى جانب كبار القاره هدى زين
الدين العربيه
الرابع
للفوز كي يعبر دور المجموعات كانت مباراه
الذهاب انتهت بفوز توتنهام
كانت هذه ابرز اخبار الرياضه وعوده الان
الى خالد مدخلين استكمال الرابعه لي خالد
شكرا محمد في شرق السعوديه تواصل المؤسسه
الامير محمد بن سلمان مسك مسيره العروض
التعريفيه عبر جوله مسك تاتي هذه الجوله
في تاريخ احتفاليه ذكرى مرور 10 سنوات على
تاسيس مؤسسه مسك بهدف الوصول للشباب
السعودي والدعمه وتمكينه من المشاركه في
برامج ومبادره المؤسسه تتضمنها الجوله
عروض تفاعليه
لجوله مسك ايضا مجموعه من الفعاليات
والانشطه المصاحبه
يعرفنا عليها بشكل اكبر من الظهران مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العثيمين اهلا عبد
الرحمن المرحله التي وصلت اليها جوله مسك
في المنطقه الشرقيه
تستهدف الشباب طبعا اليوم بعمري عمرك يا
خالد لتحفيظ مقومات الابداع لديهم ايضا
لمحاوله اكتشاف المواهب اولا في اوله
وايضا محاوله اعطاء هذه الطاقات المزيد من
المحاضرات ورش العمل سادع زميلي المصور
النصر ياخذ لكم جوله في هذا المعرض طبعا
همم هذه الجوله تضم ثلاثه اقسام القسم
الاول وهو معرض مسارات مسك ما نشاهد الان
هذا المعرض لديه عده مسارات مسار الرياده
المهارات وايضا مسار القاده ومسار المجتمع
يتم من خلالها خالد التعريف بهذه المجالات
المتاحه للطاقات الشبابيه ايضا هناك معرض
اخر وهو معرض همم الصور هذا المعرض يحكي
القصص التي تعكس رحله مسك خلال عشر سنوات
طبعا همم المؤسسه تحتفل بمرور عشر سنوات
على تاسيسها محمد بن سلمان طبعا وايضا
هناك مسرح الجوله هذا المسرح يضم عدد من
المحاضرات الان بعد قليل ستبدا الجلسه
الاولى بعنوان تمكين الطاقات الشبابيه
لتطوير مسيرتهم المهنيه ايضا كما نشاهد
هناك شباب في كل زاويه في هذا المعرض
لاستقبال شباب المنطقه الشرقيه لشرح هذه
الاقسام اولا باول وايضا شرح المسرات
خادنا مسك ايضا لديها برامج ابتعاث
بالنسبه للشباب سواء المتخرجين من
الثانويه او حتى المتخرجين من الجامعه
ايضا هناك دورات تدريبيه هناك معرض عالمي
يقام كل سنه في السعوديه وايضا في دول
اخرى هناك ايضا شركات تقوم بها مسك مع
الجمعيات العالميه على راسه طبعا الامم
المتحده من خلال برامج خاصه همم تحفيز
الابداع ايضا في ما يتعلق بمجالنا خالد
الاعلام هناك تخصص المنتاج الافلام
الوثائقيه
التصوير فحتى موضوع همم الانيميشن هناك
شركه مانجا الخاصه برسوم المتحركه ايضا هي
تابعه لمؤسسه مسك فهناك عدد من المجالات
كلها تقوم على تحفيز الشباب واستخراج
الابداعات منهم وايضا تمكينهم من هذه
الفرصوره من الظهران مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي
في سلطنه عمان
خلال هذا الموسم لسكان واهالي يا سلطنه
عمان
ودعت ظفار فصل الخريف باستقبال موسم الصرب
حيث تحصد المزروعات الموسميه في جبال
المحافظه وسهولها التي تعتمد على الامطار
في ري الاشجار الصرف كمفرده او كلمه تعني
الجمع وتعني ايضا الجز والقطه فبالنسبه
لاهالي مطار كان هذا الموسم الموسم الاكثر
رواجا وازدهارا ونشاطا
بدء بالحركه همم الزراعيه وايضا الحركه
البحريه وهمم
الراعي وما شابه بالنسبه لاهل البحر يعلن
البحر عن الفتوح ما يعرف بالفتوح الفتوح
اي ان اي ان البحر اصبح
هائلا بالحركه التجاريه والنقل العام
للسفن القادمه
والخارجه من ظفار وبالنسبه لاهل الزراعه
فهو موسم حصاد الذره وحصاد المحاصيل همم
بانواعها المختلفه كالقمح والحبوب بكل
انواعها وبالنسبه للزراعه الموسميه في
الجبل ايضا هو موسم حصاد همم المزروعات
الجبليه التي تعتمد على امطار فصل الخريف
في هذا الفصل يبدا ما يسمى قديما بالفتوح
وهو الوقت الذي تغادر فيه السفن لتشق
البحار بالتزامن مع موسم صيد السردين وما
يعرف محليا بعيد العلا
نعود الى السهول لحضور الحدث الاهم في
موسم الصرم الخطله وهي عاده عمانيه ضاربه
في القدم ففيها تغادر قطان الابل اماكنها
المؤقته في السهول عائده الى مراعيها في
الجبال في رحله سنويه تعرف باسم الخطله
تعود الخطا من الموروثات الشعبيه التي ما
زال يحافظ عليها ابناء محافظه ظفار حيث
تنزاح الابل من الجبال الى السهول في فتره
مسمى الخريف وبعد انغضاء موسم الخريف طبعا
بعد الغذاء المتخفيف ثلاثه اشهر يعود رعاه
الابل مع قطيعهم الابل من السهول مرورا
بالوديان الى الجبال
مهرجانات
سياحيه فريده في ظفار
[موسيقى]
تؤثر السحب الماطره الاتيه من بحر العرب
تؤثر على عمان والامارات وكذلك على جنوب
السعوديه بينما السحب الاتيه من افريقيا
تؤثر على بلاد الشام وعلى مصر وعلى دول
الخليج متابعه تفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد
الزعت
[موسيقى]
عاليه ومتوسطه ومنخفضه هذا هو تقسيم
السحاب بوجه عام وكل قسم يتخلله اقسام
والعامه يسمونها سحب عابره وكاتمه وماطره
العابره هي السحب الصيفيه التي تعبر
السماء من الجهه الشرقيه الى الغربيه
والكاتمه هي السحب الصيفيه المتوقفه والتي
ترفع درجات الحراره الى معدلات عاليه
صباغه اللون وطباخ التمر والماطره هي سحب
التي تاتينا من الجهه الشماليه الغربيه ان
السماء اذا لم تبكي مقلتها لم تضحك الارض
عن شيء من الخبر والزهر لا تنجلي احداقه
الا اذا مرضت من كثره المطري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
فالسحب الماطره غالبا تاتينا من افريقيا
ومن بحر العرب فهي تقطع مسافات طويله
وتنقل لنا الغبار المخصب والرطوبه النقيه
فالقادمه من افريقيا تؤثر على مصر وبلاد
الشام والعراق وتركيا وجلب بلدان الخليج
والقادمه من بحر العرب تؤثر على سلطنه
عمان والامارات واليمن وجنوب السعوديه وفي
السماء رزقكم وما توعدون فورب السماء
والارض انه لحق مثل ما انكم
تنطقون
[موسيقى]
كتبوا الرابع هذه ابرز عناوين
ساعات تفصل الجزائر عن بدء القمه العربيه
واجماع على ادانه التدخلات التركيه
والايرانيه في المنطقه
اللوجستيه المتكامله في الرياض تقدم 650
مليون عميل من ثلاث قارات
اصلاحات المناخ تقدم السعوديه عشره مراكز
في مؤشر المستقبل خلال العام الحالي
بعد فار العمانيه تعيش موسم الصرب تقليد
سنوي ومهرجانات ترفيهيه لسكان وزوار
السلطنه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]